hi everyone my name is Patrick Starr and
I'm gonna answer some fan questions by
playing with some puppies oh who
inspired me to get into makeup I think
it's you you have a smoky eye you have a
smoke my gosh I was reading my mom's
closet
and I just loved Tyra Banks I'll just
look at the Queen of glamour and I love
her so much it's not about the makeup I
think it's just being myself and
embracing Who I am to be happy what is
my number one tip for divas who have
photo facial contour the house down
contour is gonna be your best friend
like this is my best man oh my god that
kids are coming up kids are talented
inclusivity is happening brands are
taking notes and it's amazing I would
have been head to Laguna um I think I
would have been a nurse you know I'm
Filipino like we like to nurse people
and we're just such loving people and
yeah I would have been a nurse for sure
self-adhesive eyelashes we don't kind of
mess with glue might not just keep
falling off honey
natural makeup just pile it on your face
you can't think of answers you guys oh
you sweet sleepy I want to say it
probably like a thousand a thousand
brushes my skincare routine is a
cleansing oil enzyme powder a toner I
have a lot of steps moisturizer a serum
and then a hydrating mist and a lip balm
and eye cream that's a lot of products
guys mother o needs to come on my
channel and teach the kids about life
miss Oprah I love miss Oprah keep going
keep creating keep going and not just to
my younger self but to everyone out
there all the young girls out there to
keep going you keep going you keep going
[Music]
am i a big RuPaul's Drag Race now what
kind of question is that
yeah favorite queen of all time the one
who's giving everyone the opportunity
missile rooh it's my favorite queen of
all time huge thank you to Vanderpump
dogs for more information be sure to
check out the website Vanderpump dog
stork who wants to play with my shoe
[Music]